[Music]
find
right
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
a kid in front of a bed and she
made fun of muhammad without thinking
twice
never thought that i'd have to fight
your ridicule
but if you insist then just heed my
advice hope
you will be held responsible
yes he's preparing his case
[Music]
yeah legally irresponsible
half asian boo right in your face
for the life of me
i cannot decipher what made you think
that this was wise and will never
compromise for the life of me
i cannot believe you tried to ban us for
these sins now made my half asian
[Music]
[Applause]
and my friend if you think that your
legal team is better just know there's
at least one thing you can bet that when
my half asian lawyer takes the courtroom
floor
think about it now i'll be the voice
inside your head that's it
[Applause]
you will be held responsible
[Applause]
as he's preparing his case
yeah legally responsible
half asian bull right in your face for
the life of me
i cannot decipher what made you think
that this was wise and will never
compromise for the life of me
i cannot believe you try to ban us for
these sins now make my half asian
[Applause]
[Music]
he don't care if you're straight gay
trans assist
he'll chew you up like your teriyaki
bison strips and when my half asian
lawyer takes the courtroom floor he'll
seem like he's nice but you know that in
the end he'll say it
[Applause]
you will be hell responsible
[Music]
as he's preparing his cave
yeah legally responsible
[Music]
half asian blue right in your face
for the life of me
i cannot decipher what made you think
that this was wise and will never
compromise
for the life of me
i cannot believe you try to bet us for
these sins now meet my half
[Applause]
i cannot decipher what made you think
that this was wise and will never
compromise
for the life of me
i cannot believe you tried to ban us for
these sins now i made my half asian man
now make
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
yeah oh that's that's a delicious uh 19
cup of tea oh what that gas prices it's
inflation with everything oh the
increased tea that's
well yes well dang that's why we threw
it in the harbor the part of everything
yeah
people talk about the founding fathers
and they're like oh you know they would
have wanted it this way
they blew people's heads off because of
taxes on teeth yeah a preface you think
they would tolerate the government
coming in and taking your kids away
because you didn't put them on estrogen
[Laughter]
[Applause]
silly they're like ah this isn't worth
it
hey the trans kids are coming the trans
kids are coming so
we have a wrong well-tidded military yes
yes
uh and at every man's womb two
eggs ah
two wait wait what i don't know this is
a weird start hey i'm just gonna tell
you guys i think we might have kyle
written house here tomorrow hey really
he was supposed to maybe be here today
but uh uh i i think uh i think he's not
shenanigans shenanigans but uh we might
have called right now we have a big big
show today uh we're going to be talking
about the comparison here
with the detroit shooter awful terrible
lock them up throw away the key just to
be clear but why that's being classified
as terrorism and the waukesha driver
is not
that's a little odd to me
uh we'll also be talking about prices
with oil and trevor no actually got
something right he did which is
important yeah look we have to give
credit where credit is due not even uh
trevor noah got something right ah so we
talked about all that but first uh we
want to get to this quickly gerald a how
are you i'm well sir how are you you
know i'm okay i choked on an almond
earlier and almost died that's true
banned almonds i banned almonds in the
studio forever if i see one almond in
this studio i will have your scalp it
just makes common sense it's like a
native uh we have a quarter black uh
totally white guy i'm not eating almonds
okay so it's good totally white what
about almond joys
[Music]
trick question they're not allowed in
here either dang it and uh he's gonna be
performing at the fox theater in hayes
kansas
on uh february 12th at the majestic
theater in dallas uh when are you oh
sorry january 8th at the fox theater uh
quickest man on his feet dave landa how
are you ahoy how about you good sir am i
right i'm still getting i'm still
getting over the almond trauma that was
a bit much yeah
it's that actually it turns out the
roast that he tells me makes it eat uh
roasted is better yeah all the raw for
you the raw foodists uh you know all the
andy dicks of the world yeah you're
wrong is that somebody calls it that's
what he called it i remember he was on
david letterman one time and dave's like
you know you're uh you're you're you're
you're looking better andy raw food dave
you're like that's uh that's not a
ringing endorsement no no because you
just tried to have sex with the lamp
post
i thought it was just broccoli
uh really quickly too
just so you know
i don't know what's gonna happen we have
written house on this show tomorrow uh
if we're ever not on youtube you're
letting our last show is uh not this
tuesday next tuesday uh give me the date
for that token on i forget what the date
is then we're taking a break for
christmas up until then and unless we
tell you if you don't see us on youtube
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
we are streaming you can go to rumble
you can go to mug club yeah this is the
21st 21st 21st tuesday the 21st four
days before yes well it's a poor excuse
for picking a man's pocket every
december 22nd 23rd 24th but stop it stop
it with your donation schedule for the
fire yeah it was a great gift coal very
useful but you know what though this is
something uh honestly
i was raised in a socialist province
quebec now if we're going to get to this
in a little bit
a lot of people i don't know what the
price is right now of gas in quebec it's
got to be close to six dollars i know
they do it by liter it's definitely more
than california yeah and we had to deal
with these gas prices our entire life
and inflation remember as a kid anyone
out there you know what comment if
you're in canada or if you remember if
i'm 34 years old uh n64 games i remember
i couldn't get goldeneye because it was
like 79.99
i had no idea that we were screwing you
guys yes
that's really expensive because they're
like 30 bucks here yeah really yeah
exactly i think it might have been like
69.99 but it might have been 89.99 with
the expansion pack oh remember that
remember that lie what a scam yeah come
on nintendo even the back your books and
stuff have your goofy price on it you're
like why would i pay nine dollars more
yeah i don't i don't need 9.99 for cat
fancy
i don't have that
i'm not made of cat fancy money it's not
gonna happen
how am i gonna get rich with this book
if i'm spending money like this but i
just wonder if people see the price is
this the first time in your life that
you've seen this kind of inflation and
these prices and you could be doing i
see what president former vice president
joe biden is doing
i see how he's blaming opec i see how
he's now saying you know what hey you're
going to keep those oil prices down
we're going to punish you i see what
they're doing in trying to manipulate
the energy sector and i just wonder if
americans are going hey there are empty
shelves hey prices are high across the
board okay great gas went down by an
average of three cents but now it's
going back up if you understand why
because i lived it for years it was a
shock when i came to the united states i
think when i first moved she was like
what guy
what
it's so cheap well because at first i
thought it was really expensive because
we go by the liter and you guys go by
the gallon right oh my gosh and they go
no that's by the gallon it's about uh a
third of your price
and you guys complain about gas prices
because they could be lower i can't even
open stephen's apostrophe diner in
quebec without being hauled out in cuffs
because of the language police that's an
actual thing it's an actual thing so my
point is americans who are complaining
you can shut up also today is uh it's uh
the 80th i believe anniversary it is
that's right i hate using the word
anniversary well it's the 80th day of
remembrance for pearl harbor yeah where
i like to think of it more where uh you
know the day that started us making
those japs have to pay that's true
that's where his people over here
attacked us so token allen no meth
when the uh when the boys came home and
like that guy kissed that gal in times
square
just to be metoo'd 75 years later yeah
it's unfortunate it's just unbelievable
if they knew what they were fighting i
could have got a peck on the cheek but
he dipped me
yeah oh no
all right before we get to any of that
uh
the fat i don't i haven't watched this
sorry and look i want to be really clear
people say why why do you why do you
pick on fat people first off no
i never made fun of people who are just
overweight i want to be clear uh i have
talked about i'm almost brought to tears
when i see overweight people at the gym
and i always talk about encouraging the
issue i'm laughing
no i'm sure come on dave that was one
time because the treadmill made you move
in a funny waddle it did
it always does
it was a pigeon toe run yeah it's not
really and he coos too man he gets out
of breath he greasy breathes in he goes
i do
cool i do i have no idea why that
effective it's funny it's not coming out
of my mouth my heart makes it yes
i thought about it you shouldn't have
got that fourth booster
they said i had to where i can't see my
kids
[Laughter]
derailed the entire show already all
right
my issue is with the fat positivity
movement where we are telling kids
that it is beautiful and healthy it's
not and we have an obesity problem in
this country and it's even more
important when you're talking about
socialized healthcare that's what you're
pushing for we do need to acknowledge
something about the science which by the
way twitter is now miss they're they're
labeling as misleading and fake news the
american heart association we're going
to get into that so my point is when
twitter says american heart association
you're wrong
but lizzo you should be offering dietary
advice you know the lizzo pyramid
which is just her attempting to do a
handstand and those those those those
panties which are really more oblong
than a pyramid those arms can't hold
that up it's the lizzo oblong all right
so the fat positivity movement uh they
now have made gargantuan strides on the
tick-tock
[Music]
[Music]
well that's not a stereotype now is it
not at all
looks like they
looks like they tied her down to a truck
it looks like it's holding her together
why it looks like bungee cords
okay all right how long is this it keeps
going
wow
[Music]
okay all right enough this is enough
there was more was that age restricted
for kids on tick-tock stick talk is
different can you imagine they just did
push those tickets yeah i appreciate her
uh cardiovascular uh capabilities there
honestly it's impressive yeah
sure i appreciate his upper body
strength when she did the backward dip
thing and he was holding her up yeah can
you imagine him dipping her in times
square like oh we got a new manhole so
that's
coming home from war yeah just like so
terrible he dips or she falls and ninja
turtles like where you ruined my junior
suite what's going on
pizza dude oh no no not this one she ate
the pizza dude oh no all right uh here's
something else too that we uh are going
to talk about because white liberals
have to ruin absolutely everything yes
um
they're trying to distance themselves
now
from latinx yeah just to be clear that
this was trending yesterday
because of a new poll that came out on
and then on the twitter it was trending
and you have all these prominent
liberals and writers at places like
salon and saying like well you know what
we're just like well you're just these
fake culture wars we didn't even no no
no no get back here yeah i want you to
stand right next to what you tried to
made a thing
you tried to make latinx a thing you now
have to own it and just so you don't
have to take my word for it take a look
it's in a clip right now is almost
entirely attributable to immigration
whose latinx community has added a
tremendous amount so let's be clear
folks are hunting what happened to that
googly eyed americans
uh lg hunting latin americans it's doing
great for people who want to invest in
private prisons just not for the african
americans and latinx whose families are
torn apart it's awful hard as well
to get
a t-nex actually oh that's different
it's a little different there they're
worried that they'll be vaccinated and
deported the way he says it sounds like
drain cleaner yeah can you get the
latinx and i just shaved my balls in the
shower
just talking about hunter's hard drive
yes
not a joke get him a t-nex
i love how she didn't know how to
pluralize it she's like oh the latinx
was it latinx's what is it because you
screwed up the romance languages it
doesn't make any sense hispanics hate
you well her cookbook for mexican food
is coming out yes yes she's working
she's one 1064 uh mexican yes exactly
well something about the mayans and the
natives i don't know i'm not abuela will
make her something i i actually i'm not
sure that she's not uh she's not a
descendant from the conquistadors well
people in the funny hats with the red
beards i love how he says that cory
booker too were uh you know they're
hunting latinx what does that mean can
he just please go away he has gone i'm
hunting now he's still around for what
he's gonna resurface eventually and say
something stupid and look googly-eyed at
the camera yeah he'll be pulled out of
the swamp on an episode of river
monsters oh look i caught myself a
booker
we're hunting
you're hunting them no they work pretty
hard they're they're everywhere yeah i
don't i don't know hunting yeah it's not
hard involved and if you want to look
for them just look for them protesting
and making fun of beta o'rourke they're
all over yeah
just trashing him at his own event i
love how biden was saying too that part
of the punishment they're like they're
afraid of getting vaccinated and being
deported like both of them are things
they're afraid of right yeah like yeah
you said the quiet part out loud yeah i
also feel like one of those things is
their concern yes
well they're hesitant
white supremacy
got to clean the train otherwise that's
kind of great other ones after that so
we actually did this before and now it's
catching on uh it's catching some steam
this is from a while actually a clip
where we all went out to ask people just
started for me in the office saying i
just don't think latinx is a thing yeah
i think that there are things that exist
in twitter that are not real world and
then uh there's reality and i have not
met anyone in real life and certainly
not has
a hispanic american who prefers latinx
let's just go ask people and you can
watch the full clip the link is in the
description but this was a while ago do
you refer to yourself as
latino latina or latinx
because now they're saying latinx is the
term is that have you heard that latina
[Music]
curious if people actually call each
other latinx
i don't really know that word have you
heard the term latin latinx
okay to be referred to like latinx or
latina
latina latina
yeah have you heard that no i haven't
heard of that yeah you never heard of
latinx mexicana latina mexicana
well now that's like the the like pc
term yeah i know you're supposed to say
latinx i don't like that
half of them thought they were on the
jamie kennedy experiment well yes
so uh
now another poll that was released uh
shows that guess how many hispanic
voters prefer latinx take a guess um
five
you tank ten come on don't okay look
don't undershoot it so it makes me look
like an idiot fifty is two
oh two that next got two
geez oh they're not even fully left no
they're not two percent of hispanic
voters describe themselves as latinx uh
40 of respondents actually said they
were at least somewhat bothered
wow by the term
30 even said they would probably not
support a candidate who used the term so
by all means miss pow-wow chow please
don't let us interrupt you well it
sounds like a mutant like x-men i mean
it doesn't it never made sense to me
latin x it's either porn or mutant are
you glad next no bro i can't move things
with my mind yes
i got wolverine claws yeah you know no
latinx adamantium's not a real thing bro
you're like uh actually i have it in my
chest right now i don't
[Laughter]
your letters with these you know meaning
see that's humor guys
yeah that's why it's funny because you
came up with latinx like a bunch of
yeah
i hope they don't watch this and stop
using it i want them to continue
hardcore well now they're trying to
distance themselves from it so according
to one latino democratic congressional
aide this is from the atlantic a lot of
my colleagues will advise their bosses
against using it when speaking to
spanish-speaking constituencies because
it from what they have perceived is a
creation of white english speakers okay
a couple of things it's not perceived
from white english speakers okay it's
not perception it's reality second even
here when speaking the atlantic
anonymously this person's like uh when
speaking to uh
spanish-speaking constituencies they say
hispanic they all said we prefer
hispanic you still can't you still can't
stop tripping over your own balls
and most really prefer american yes yeah
i mean if you're in america obviously
but yeah and most feel like common yeah
most probably don't want to be pandered
to anyway like come on just be real with
these people don't try to come up with
something you can label them as me like
see i'm cool what especially when pow
wow
taco lady decides that it's going to be
latinx like that's the person who are
going to follow suits which by the way
canada the cbc the canadian broadcasting
corporations just issued a guideline of
terms you shouldn't use and on there
were terms like you know egypt spirit
animal soul down the river blackmail
blacklist and powwow was on their own oh
really so the title come on the title of
elizabeth warren's book is hate speech
wait blackmail a crime can't be
mentioned they said because it it it
implies that black is not what about
black friday
i have no idea what about getting into
the black in uh business because that
means it has to be money poc mail yes ah
yes when you go black our business is
now poc what does that mean it's
profitable
[Laughter]
what about that that guy has a black
shirt on it's funny
it has to do with the darkness behind
what it is it has nothing to do with
skin i know that's not just like amen
has nothing to do with penises
that's true or a woman no or a woman
well that's true nothing to do with
penises or vaginas because although that
sherman hensley sure could jump rope
well i don't know if you're right but
here's one thing too
you know what the i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna come this is something that
has bothered me for a long time first
off the left turns everything racist and
we're going to get into the terrorism
and the shooting and the running people
over in a second and i don't mean jokes
i mean actual racism look
this is something where people say what
are you about you have a black friend
yeah okay we do have
latinos who work here hispanic people
working we've had quite a few hispanic
people who've worked here quite a few
asian people when someone says you're
auntie
latino you're anti-hispanic and you say
well no hold on a second i i spend time
with are you able to say you have a
hispanic friend that's actually a pretty
good indicator that someone doesn't hate
them if someone has black friend no one
in the clan had black friends to be
clear right no one who actually hates
illegal immigrants uh sorry legal
immigrants i don't know no one who
actually has hatred for legal americans
who are brown has them as friends and
this is what happens it's all about
words and not about actions what is
friendship seriously let's what is
friendship
friendship with someone hanging out with
it's a reciprocal relationship with
someone you care about who cares about
you typically friendship means that you
should be giving selflessly that you
should be there for support for your
friend that's an if you are doing that
with someone who is not your skin color
that matters more than if you use the
right term or you tell a joke that
offends some white broad so yes it is a
perfectly valid example to point to if
you have brown or black friends or
you're probably not a racist they want
to remove it just because they want you
to oh that's off the tip no it's not off
the table it is not off the table okay
duke robert byrd didn't have black
friends
no it's true though and no friends you
know i think larry bird every time you
say that i know that's true and to be
fair in that video they probably was
surrounded by black friends yeah
opposite swarmed by them really yeah
[Laughter]
to be fair they thought quarter black
was one of their people yeah in that
video there was no way that they thought
he was i got in there yeah you know
there's nothing wrong
which by the way every friend of all
colors is all i'm saying
maybe some uh with benefits right yeah
dj hit it
i'm very disappointed that you were able
to hit it that quickly i don't know what
that was
that was me making it sexual what a sad
state of affairs that he was at the
ready
also you're a horrible dj yeah
like hey kate what are you playing next
it's my song
[Laughter]
look that's all you could get to write
or you just played everyone's hammer
they go there like
shots shots chat oh she's trying to say
shots i guess so it was the original
bozo's last words
[Laughter]
yeah and then cookie covered him with a
pillow
and stole a crisp one hundred dollars
which he hid in the front of his shoe
it took a while to get it out they get
those chilean miners all right hey you
can uh
listen to the podcast
uh on audio spotify apple android for
people you know for if you if you're not
in rumble or mug club and uh
comment if you have you ever had people
say if you you're like oh i hang out
with i have black friends
and they go oh are you saying that it
must be you're a racist don't don't
allow them to do it don't allow them to
do anymore you're like yeah no it
actually shows that i'm probably not a
racist you say things that they perceive
as racist like latinx and i actually you
know break bread with them so maybe
you're the problem elizabeth warren or
just say what no and see how they deal
with that yes
that's the whole difference that's the
other option you know what i mean it's
like
horribly uncomfortable yeah just make
the room just completely like oh dear
all right why would i i do have to
address something here really quickly no
i don't i don't typically like
addressing media matters because you
have a bunch of uh conservatives who
their whole show turns into a back and
forth right yeah i really just find them
incredibly entertaining and the fact
that we know they have a mug club
membership
so out of touch they support the show
they do the show they clip our videos
it's great advertising it's ironic that
they go after spot to try and boycott
sponsors but they pay for a membership
that's very funny so yesterday and dave
just said you just you have to run this
because uh i'm about to read you a
headline for me that was meant to offend
you
and of course i stand by it
of course every word it says do we have
the overlay first or do we just have the
uh no okay so look
i mean i look the headline reads on
youtube stephen crowder
said i would like to send out gangs of
[ __ ] people
to uh lynch pedophile
still fun and so i guess today for the
medium it's time for today's media
matters moment
[Music]
thank
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i don't think i use the word gangs but
you know what i'll allow it that sounds
even better actually it's pretty close
it's actually not i don't even remember
saying it that's not a bad idea
i just who's sitting around going you
know what's worse than pedophilia the r
word yes let's put this out there and i
think everyone will get behind our
movement i'm surprised they didn't
settle on like packs or schools yes yeah
schools of special needs a murder of
retards
lynchings you'll get it eventually when
you're a jet you're jet all the way also
why are they i hate that they dehumanize
that
like they're the ones dehumanizing them
not you or me when we were saying that
no and by the way people don't realize
that special needs people are actually
the most very often sexually abused when
they're young it's very common because
they're they they are easily led astray
they're very trusting having worked with
and volunteered with for years and my
wife even more so special needs people i
also don't think it would be too hard to
send them in the right direction like a
wind-up toy with just the rap sheet of
the pedophiles and let nature take its
course yeah
god gave them extra strength true
they're like berserkers for a reason yes
and we mean that as a compliment in the
best way we do yep yes and the only
thing is be sure not to wear your your
light up shoes when you go because you
need it they're not good for sneaking
no then the little destroyer really yeah
and sometimes they'll slip on on the
roller shoes yes exactly no healing
shoes for killing pedophiles
they're going to be so bad
people are already upset let's open up
leather souls oh everybody has had has
handicapped people in immensely any kind
of people in their life and their family
and what are you saying you have a
[ __ ] friend yeah yeah look i'm just
saying i'm from
i believe it's tardy x yes
how dare you because this is the issue
they're more offended at words
and by the way [ __ ] comes from
avatar is a term in french it means slow
late to arrive this is something right
[ __ ] note that people talk about
music it's only offensive now because
people have said that it's offensive now
that's the issue how you treat people
with handicap special needs mental
retardation is more important than the
word you say especially if for some
reason i don't know why the left please
we might even have written house on the
show tomorrow in every case you're not
just defending pedophiles you're pet
naming them
jojo jojo they're defending them yeah
that's the part i don't understand if i
want to send out gangs of people with
special needs to lynch pedophiles don't
give them a heads up
and let them make their own decisions if
they're down they're down they're down
you know what just a few uh few 2 for 20
appetizers might help grease the wheels
don't try to control them yeah we're not
come on just saying no i mean them you
know they're crying out there all the
play-doh you can eat
i'm kind of [ __ ] it's so salty she's
deliberately going too far to make the
point well you know what don't worry
you'll be on the cover this time don't
worry whatever you say will be over my
face yes they'll say yes
exactly
this co-host made fun of our
the literally
best headline i've ever read he texted
me when i was sitting at the conference
table i have never laughed that hard in
my life come out his face is red like
what are you laughing he goes gangs of
dirty people pitching butterflies
they think they think people are going
to be mad at this
i took it personally i think
who why because they're part of the gang
or they're the ones who will be lynched
my point is who are you hey if you were
to if you were toss-up if you were to
play the odds a reader of media matters
you think it's more likely they're in
the gang or being lynched uh probably in
the game no probably being like oh sorry
as you said
yeah i thought you meant media matters
reader that's true of course
yes there that's why they're like hey
whoa this might create a all their
readers are sending and this might
create a ground swell we've got to put a
stop to this
i mean we had a little special we had a
special needs friend we'd give him
cigarettes and stuff now i know that's
wrong but we still treated him
as if he was one of our friends yeah
well you didn't have to hand him a
cigarette backwards oh no oh no
it's like lucy in the football he wanted
to smoke what am i going to say to him
uh i know you're you're
where his parents okay so there's
another high school that we head to the
special room i i don't know anyone who
actually works with special who i was
there if you say the word [ __ ] now
if you call someone a a [ __ ] right
just to and even then i've done that to
him guilty of that just like people
everyone's get i don't care whatever so
oh sorry i honestly stopped using the
word for a long time just based on that
but never in my life did i ever mean it
to be a mentally handicapped of course
not ever no that's the part that i don't
get it's like oh i thought it just meant
somebody was dumb yeah that was all we
ever normal friend of mine that i just
didn't like in that moment right that's
exactly right yeah then you hand him a
backwards cigarette let nature take its
course whereas in 1960 when they were
like i think he's got a bit of
retardation let's electroshock therapy
yes like that was the problem
first we're going to put them on a chair
and that's going to be dipped backwards
into electric water
we think that will get rid of the [ __ ]
gene yes by the way five out of six
doctors recommend chesterfields
a smooth pull smooth pull for those
pregnant ladies oh lord don't be don't
forget to look at the suns love
the science charm this baby yes
or
as we call them soon to be president jfk
same thing you're on the right track
who loves you baby
don't be afraid to have some chardonnay
with that parliament so
uh twitter this is also very scary
because this is when people say it's a
culture war you're damn right you're
damn right and people trying to change
words and also change
the biological
scientific parameters of what a man and
what a woman is and then use that
culturally to try and remove children
from their parents yeah you know what it
starts with controlling words and it
starts with telling people actually
rather than actions words that offend
are are going to be policed and we'll
make sure that we eliminate anyone from
you know the public discourse if you say
what we don't like so here's what's so
scary about it twitter
decided that they were going to put a
warning label on the tweets of the
american heart
association oh lord
which said that the mrna vaccines
increase the risk of heart disease now i
want to be really clear here before we
do that uh
see um cnn nbc the new york times
washington post and of course a lot of
these i don't know if they are
third-party fact-checkers for the big
tech websites but all the major
publications have regularly cited the
american hearth association as an
authoritative source so here's the issue
when people say well you know
authoritative sources are what are
important brian stelter super straight
we need authoritative news like you
reliable sources it's a that you lie in
the name now
news you can swallow oh
[Laughter]
goes down sweet no no no move on
i feel a rumbly in my tumbly time for
something news so
um just reaching into a tree grabbing
the honey the bees are like no he's back
so my point here is they all cite this
as authoritative they tell you that
don't listen to shows like this who list
all of our references of ability of
color.com link in the description right
we just try i'm biased but i try and be
as transparent as possible i don't
believe that anyone out there is
incapable of not bringing their own
biases to the table walter cronkite yes
brian williams yes dan rather of course
unbiased news has never actually existed
it's a lie if you believe that it has i
just ask that people are honest with you
and here's the thing they're saying you
need authoritative sources but they're
not even consistent themselves follow
the science well the authoritative
source that you've been using for
decades
says
the science tells us that the mrna
vaccine increases risk of heart disease
let's remove them from the science yeah
remove them why because fauci says
they're wrong
okay hold on a second
fouchy
american heart association
fauci
american heart association hold on hold
on heart yes so it's it's like these
people would know a little bit about
cardiovascular issues right maybe yeah
well the other one has no heart you're
still waiting to get it from the wizard
yeah everything's delayed in shipping
by the way do you remember when this
happened when they said you couldn't
contradict the who and the cdc
contradicted wh like the next day yeah
that's been happening the label from
twitter the american heart association
right this is that the mrna vaccines
increase the risk of heart disease this
is kind of their specialty the twitter
label says warning this link may be
unsafe the link you are trying to access
has been identified by twitter or our
partners as being potentially spammy or
unsafe in accordance with twitter's url
policy the link could fall into any of
the below categories malicious links
that could steal personal information or
harm electronic devices no spammy links
that mislead people or disrupt their
experience no violent or misleading
content that could lead to real world
harm no certain categories of content
that if posted directly on twitter are a
violation of the twitter rules well hold
on a second why did you list all those i
thought those were the rules the nice
thing or if it could be of isolation of
these well what uh and that's it or any
other rules well what's that depending
on uh what our h1 visa guy says today
well it's not us it's uh our partners
yes oh it's so i mean just like hunter
biden we're not sure the hunter biden
story from new york post
do you really honestly honestly because
i know we have some people here who are
not who are not conservative who watch a
lot
you right now
do you really believe the left is the
party of science right now is it the
party of science at the party of fouchy
is the american heart i get that i'm not
a scientist is the american heart
association not allowed a place at the
table
is that really where we are
and you're gonna take the moral high
road
this is terrifying well this is why we
were screaming at the top of our lungs
when this started and said look you're
silencing individual doctors because you
don't like their opinion and then you
silenced ron desantis when he had a
meeting with a doctor from oxford and a
doctor from harvard yeah if those are
not doctors i get you don't like their
opinion you literally censored his video
a sitting governor one of the largest
states population economic wise in the
united states that was dealing with a
pandemic just like everybody else and
you wouldn't let him talk and you know
what really quickly too this is why i
always say give not one inch because
early on people said well those are just
dot remember the doctors who uh from
california were banned right they said
those are just some doctors that's
anecdotal even though they see thousands
of patients which is clinical it's all
over the second they see one patient
that's more than fouchy in three decades
but people say well that's not really
authoritative then you have the verse
system that's being reported on right
for vaccine adverse reaction and then
people say well that's not necessarily
accurate then you have the mayo clinic
saying well let's not really act did you
really think it was going to stop at
people who you just said alex jones are
extremists now
labeled alongside the kkk is the
american heart association it's the same
label because it's all under this
umbrella of it could be violent it could
be misleading you decide no no twitter
how about you say how about you say what
the violation is it must be so nice to
be a leftist and have no accountability
none of these shows provide any sources
any references which by the way i'm not
saying that to be a martyr i'm saying it
because the reason we provide resources
here we provide the references if you
read the description it's like a
bibliography that's what i would have
wanted because i never knew what was
truthful in the news and where did he
get that that's why i do it they don't
even think you care twitter doesn't even
think you want to know hey wait a second
what about the american heart
association scientific claim is false
yeah they don't even feel the need well
they think that you can't handle hearing
something like that either like oh my
gosh it has adverse reactions i'm going
to run out and do something foolish now
or not do something that could make my
life
vaccinate a five-year-old well yeah
don't get me swearing again um look
we have the trust but verify and we got
rid of the verify we just went to trust
like oh okay well we'll just trust
whatever they say right no trust but
verify has always been your
responsibility always with everything
yeah well i don't trust the trailer
the guy whose trailer just exploded from
making meth improperly more than i do
voucher yes
he's more of a scientist to me well i
got out in time is that a reference to
the the watch and react clip no just in
general
also i
make meth now if anybody would like to
well it's as easy as chocolate chip
cookies i mean i gotta tell you it's
surprisingly easy and surprisingly keeps
you up breaking bad formulas
just saying yeah token not for you no
you don't have the enzyme that processes
it properly don't get get a little mess
in him and he is grumpy really
that just makes me feel toothless no
meth makes him mean but you know what we
all have our thing so
now we're moving on here and we're going
to go back to the why vaccines um
[Laughter]
the waukesha versus oxford shooting yeah
uh this is another example of when the
media determines what's allowed so for
example if twitter let's say facebook
let's say youtube they also was no
longer authoritative what happens when
you go into court what happens when
you're having an international summit
with scientists right oh well guess what
the american heart association is not
allowed to be included that's exactly
what happened with climate
change sorry back then it was global
warming yeah with global warming what
they they were labeled skeptics and
science deniers well they're just not
allowed by the way the sierra club
doesn't answer for all their false
predictions this is what's happening now
you're seeing remember this you are
seeing happening right now in 2022 what
happened with any scientists who
disagreed with the idea of catastrophic
climate change global warming back then
that could ultimately solved by
international government intervention
right now you are seeing a carving and a
trimming
of people who are critical of one arm of
the science and in this case i think the
american heart association
is right just my opinion
but you have to decide at this are they
allowed a seat at the table you're
seeing it happen in real time right now
and pretty soon people go back and go
all those crazy folks at the american
heart those quacks at mayo clinic
well they act like the risks they don't
see the witch doctors it's dudes right
yeah you can't trust those guys they act
like the risk is worse
for
however many people running out of doing
let's say that somebody does go out
there and say something that is
incorrect maybe they do it on accident
it's the risk is worse for silencing
voices you end up in places where
millions of people die historically yeah
just look at history when you start
silencing voices because you know better
than everybody else you're not very far
from germany in the 1930s and russia
kind of forever right that's exactly
what happens that's why we're worried
about it we understand that it's
dangerous
oh sorry right now i guess on cnn
speaking of russia there's something
about the ukraine uh is biden on the
phone with putin i don't want to look
you think you are currently in standing
shower yes yes is this guy talking
listen listen put have the room mic he
poops oh i could tell you a riddle that
will destroy the rest of your brain yes
if a plane crashes on the border of
ukraine and russia yeah where do you
bury the demented survivors oh man
what happened to the last guy who liked
his country yes who is this old man
who's this man are you tales from crypt
he just
what are we doing he just makes his head
start shaking like a fembot look it
worked he'll repeat it his friend can't
handle it left side the right side with
this guy it's all bad side
you like hockey player who've been hit
many many many many times many times
the answer is 12
what ah
that's great for a laugh
hey maybe next time we can take uh
former vice president biden and put him
in larger doll that is also inside
larger dog
and just tell him it's birthday cake yes
we have it all
tell him he is stumped double for remake
of under siege then we send them to
ukraine
and then we invade does anyone actually
think that people abroad respect this
guy come on no even if you're older i
don't think anyone has ever actually
been under those illusions with joe
biden no
all right no it's talking to frank
drebin in character yes i mean other
than the chauncey gardner blackmailed
those people over in ukraine and yeah
well hell he fired the guy right after
that
committed a crime yes justice email well
yeah come on what you're gonna see
you're gonna see putin like hey hey joe
try to blackmail me
come on do it do it try to blackmail me
what do you do
when i come to take you your women will
look away
they always
look away
you ain't black
you want to have naked shower fight yes
we do that the eastern promises
yes
what fun
so
the oxford school shooter has been
charged with multiple counts including
terrorism here in michigan now
uh the oakland county prosecutor karen
mcdonald said that the charges were
warranted what about all the children
who ran screaming hiding under desks
what about all the children at home
right now who can't eat and can't sleep
and who can't imagine a world where
those are okay look uh the charge of
terrorism reflects that
two things can be in one statement one
can be true and one it's not yeah
of course
people are empathetic to lives lost
that's also why i believe that more
people should be allowed to own guns
because there are far far far far far
far far more exponentially more
defensive uses of firearms every year
than those used in mass shootings or
even homicides with firearms it's not
even close so i'm going to assume that
you are operating from a place of
empathy and compassion okay i'm not
going to do what you guys did however
the accuracy of the term terrorism i
call in the question why terrorism is a
violent act with an ideological or
political motive behind it seeking an
ideological or politically
charged outcome that's not what we saw
in michigan
um
now i understand that the michigan law
is a little bit broader i'm talking
about how the media has also labeled
this the media has labeled it terrorism
on the flip side uh we have what
happened in waukesha running people over
um
here's the deal there is nothing at
oxford with this shooter from michigan
nothing at all
that suggests
he was motivated by politics by religion
it really seems like this was a mentally
disturbed person there is no there is no
motive thus far right
i don't know how that's terrorism now on
the flip side
the waukesha killer in wisconsin had
very clear disdain for white people had
committed acts of violence before and
said he would commit acts of violence
that would be racially motivated just to
be clear we did a whole segment on this
i'll just give you a quick recap um he
said learned nd behavior so when we
start back knocking this is college
back knocking white people tf i don't
want to hear it the old white people too
knocked them pardon my language the [ __ ]
out melanated worldwide revolution laws
legally allowing white supremacy um
now this is something the reason that
this is happening in oxford is they made
every single effort the media to try and
link the shooter the kid to his parents
and his mom supported donald trump yeah
so there you go it's got to be that
might mean it's racially motivated as
opposed to this waukesha how many people
died in waukesha is it seven i think we
were looking i don't think we have the
number because i know that unfortunately
more people died later on down the line
two years of grotesquely handling the
pandemic messing with kids heads leaving
them inside of a room and eventually
having them go crazy i guess you could
parallel that with terrorism if that
bugged him a bit yeah no you
mispronounced his mom sent a note to
trump oh my god oh that's what it was
now we know now here's the thing
political opinion yeah she had a
political opinion you know what else
people don't like to talk about
and i want to take this moment to
highlight a hero an actual hero not a
nurse tick-tocking right um tate meyer
he's a kid who died yeah
trying to tackle it trying to save other
people yeah guess what his mom liked
donald trump on facebook
just to be clear and you know what this
is not something that uh is uncommon
because this morality does matter and
the problem i have with black lives
matter and the reason i think it can
lead to domestic terrorism and it's a
domestic terrorist organization is
because it's wrong it's immoral to hate
people or vilify people because of the
color of their skin i don't think
there's anything wrong
morally with someone thinking that biden
is a better candidate i think they're
wrong factually i don't think that
warrants terrorism i think black lives
matter does i think antifa does i don't
think a mom saying hey thank you donald
trump for thinking about us the middle
class this was in the handwritten letter
she didn't say get rid of get rid of the
blacks
she said thanks for trying to bring jobs
back uh back to our shores i don't think
that qualifies as terrorism i think
black lives matter saying get rid of the
nuclear family and get rid of white
people musicians
of power regardless
of how they attain them i think that
that's actually racist but what we're
talking about is tate meyer who tackled
who tried to stop the shooter yeah we
also have to look at the ideological
motivation of a lot of people who
stopped shooters now i gave you that
stat before 500 000 anywhere from 500
000 to 3 million on a given year the
average seems to be about 2 million
defenses uses defensive uses of firearms
contrasting with tens of thousands of
homicide deaths anywhere between 15 to
25 000 hummus with firearms it's not
even close who do you think are the
people most likely to be defending
themselves their family and their fellow
citizens with those firearms so tate
meyer
we don't know his political motivation
just like we don't know the motivation
of the oxford shooter we do know his mom
likely was conservative
and we do know when you look at this
people who stop shooters they tend to be
conservatives
or often black guys yeah black guys
who've had enough yeah yeah black guys
have had enough in their neighborhood
what do we have we had stephen williford
on here southern one springs how many
people were killed they're 20 something
people
yeah were killed he was an ar
uh uh not only an ar instructor well he
was an nra instructor but um i think he
shot him with an ar-15 if i'm not
mistaken i believe so i believe so so
what do we have we have
uh we have kyle rittenhouse we have
david dorn that officer a black man who
i don't know if he was conservative or
not his wife obviously is conservative
serving his neighborhood james kilser is
someone you look at the pattern here and
what you see is sure okay there are
people who can go random and commit acts
of violence and if you want to attribute
that to donald trump that's a little bit
of a stretch i think the waukesha driver
committed an act of violence in the name
of a racially motivated crime
because he said hey everyone set your
clocks i want to hurt white people
effectively that's why i take he said
that he would and i take him at his word
but i also think it's important to note
that hey there's a consistent trend
we'll never get the numbers on this
who's stopping the shootings
invariably when you look at these heroes
that matters too if we're going to use
it going both ways but instead
this why do you think tate meyer isn't
championed more on air that's an actual
hero that yeah i don't know i mean i
know they they put some emphasis behind
what he did but i don't think nearly
enough right just like we were talking
about what kyle did it was like that was
just an incredible thing for him to show
the restraint that he showed and to
defend himself without just shooting
other people that he thought might have
been a threat like we focused on this
for a reason because we had evidence of
it right now what we have evidence of is
you guys saying that a car drove through
a parade right you said an suv drove
through a parade and then we have
evidence of you guys putting out
something that says this guy feels like
he's being dehumanized he's been made
into a monster no he is a monster yes
his difference made him a monster yeah
we don't know anything yet now if if
this prosecutor knows something that we
don't know which i'm assuming that they
do i still don't know how this goes to
terrorism when i has any other school
shooting been attributed or kind of i'm
sure there's there's i don't know
there's a reason why a guy was lit on
bail i can't remember what oh yeah what
was that one i remember that because we
experienced that live remember in fort
worth and we were watching all the
trucks all the helicopters when there's
a shooting remember it was it was
wall-to-wall oh my god
and then we said well hold on a second
why
well like a fart in the wind how did
they all vanish yeah what happened too
oh then we found out what it was it was
a black kid who went and shot a teacher
over uh over a scuffle that had happened
before and he was let out on bail yeah
and elizabeth warren didn't show up as a
mother no
aoc didn't fly down and cry next to a
parking lot either and i know a lot of
people in michigan that are like afraid
now uh you know they're sort of locked
into their they've
you know shut down a lot of high schools
and stuff just for the week and
everything and i
i it really bothers me because if you
look at it okay if you look at both
these situations and i i really want to
say i feel exceptionally
bad for all the lives lost then the
eight-year-old boy who was marching with
his little league team that got hit by
like
it just makes me infuriated so let's say
if you want to look at the the guy who
drove into the parade that he felt
dehumanized well how do you know that
this other kid who shot at the school
didn't you look at all the rhetoric
going on on twitter telling him that
he's a monster that he's evil you have
no idea if he's being bullied i'm not
defending him right but i'm saying we're
locking people up in our in mentally one
way or another
right now we're at war with each other
the country's in half we're fighting
over vaccines where there's this
constant struggle where i can't imagine
being a teenager right now mentally it's
got to be
i do feel that the media is complicit in
this and i think it's why we're seeing
more of this yeah i firmly do believe
that and i'm not i'm not excusing either
behavior it's both disgusting and
the reason why the kid is why um
uh
tate tate meyer tate meyer is not being
held as a hero as much is because it
takes the racial aspect out of it
yeah and that's the reality yeah and you
know what i think is really scary too
when we're talking about kids
uh
take imagine peer pressure right when
you were a kid now when we were
teenagers there was something kind of
cool about rebellion now there's peer
pressure media pressure faculty pressure
government pressure and it's all in one
direction for compliance yep yep yeah
that's a scary so you're right we are
fighting over vaccines the problem is
kids who think independently kids who
may have you know read the email despite
twitter's best efforts read the american
heart association report
they are being vilified by their
teachers by their deans by their faculty
members by other kids parents by the
little league coach this is think about
that for a second we are telling kids
submit no rebellion why because they
want to make sure that everyone follows
in line with the media they want to make
sure everyone follows online everyone
used to think that when donald trump
would be president i remember having
this conversation when i was at fox news
worked there for four years and uh a lot
of them thought mitt romney was going to
win
so
i remember they said like you know
actually would be bad for business
because you know it's always being the
opposition party is better for ratings
and i said
oh you you and i don't do the same thing
so i said my my fight isn't i mean if
you would take the power of the white
house or washington dc over hollywood
and new york city and the media you you
need a cat scan this the authority right
now
in this country is it's all one and the
same right now you've got an unholy
alliance of government of legacy media
and now all of big tech trying to prop
them up the education establishment
right now we see the scientific
community
excommunicating
yeah basically getting rid of the
american heart association as though
they're apostates nuts and we're telling
kids this is the only point of view and
if you don't fall in line you're a bad
person so i i always find influence well
why are we fighting why are we well
because you guys are all saying there's
only one way look i'm not none of us
here are saying there's only one way
we're saying there's a couple of ways
and by the way the american heart
association should be included in that
way we're saying hey there are many ways
to try and cut down on school shootings
and by the way just stripping everyday
citizens their right to carry firearms
and women and disabled people the right
to protect themselves is not one of the
ways so we're saying there are many ways
but some ways are preferable and some
ways aren't the same thing when they say
with abortion right they make an
all-or-nothing game the left and if
you're a teenager i can only imagine how
difficult this is what if you're
pro-life they go your anti-choice why do
you want to take control of women's
bodies no i'm not anti-choice i'm
pro-four choices just not the fifth
motherhood adoption abstinence
chastity wait
motherhood contraception abstinence
adoption just not five murder and you
say it's all or nothing for crying out
loud hobby lobby let's put this in
context provided 16 different kinds of
birth control for their employees and
you called them sexist fascists because
they didn't give them another four
go screw yourself give any idea what
that does to a kid in school when people
in positions of authority are saying no
no only one way our way period wait uh
hold on teacher i think maybe there's
some way that like i think maybe biology
plays some role in sex or gender no
there's only one way there is no science
as it relates to biology or gender wait
hold on professor uh i think maybe
maybe
the second amendment is no no the second
amendment needs to be stripped and we
need to make sure wait hold on a second
professor i think that maybe
maybe the american heart association is
no no you will comply it's that the left
today is the only party that has
one way
and then they blame people for fighting
we're just going hey how about many ways
yeah one for snapping i'm sorry go ahead
jerry but i mean there's a point where
you're holding in rebellion so much that
you just snap yeah well and you're being
pushed you talked about that pressure i
have i have a son in about three and a
half or so years he's going to be going
into the education system and this is
what pissed me off so much about not
putting a public school are you i didn't
say a public school the education system
right so i can only imagine with his
size your genetics in a public school
that is blonde hair blue eyes
sorry buddy that's totally your dad's
fault
no but what i'm saying is that that's
what pissed me off so much is because
i'm just thinking i'm like
he won't he won't have a chance think
about living in new york and going hey
you can't go on your your field trip to
this place because they're going to go
and do this really cool thing you've
been looking forward to but you can't go
because you don't have a vaccine or you
can't eat dinner at a restaurant you
know you can't do anything how do you
make a kid understand why he's being
othered in that way by the government
right i'm not talking about a kid
picking on him or something that
happened no no by the way none of this
has to do with the shooting we're just
talking about right now a climate that
we're creating and then pointing to an
inanimate object like a gun or like an
suv what matters is look there does have
to be
creating makes these repercussions yes
well i would say the climate of saying
there is no right and wrong and we're
going to blame objects and we're just
going to vilify people who disagree with
us look there's one side like we just
talked about accountability
everyone here if you ask us will answer
on any given issue whether we believe
okay this is right or this is wrong i
will answer you on abortion i will
answer you on the idea of the federal
government and taxes and what is
appropriate i will answer you on the
second amendment i will answer you on
the first amendment the issue here is we
have one group of people who don't have
to answer for anything don't ever have
to answer for anything wait a second the
guy was quoting you when he ran over
people
he was quoting your rhetoric
you don't know so if we have to answer
because
a kid's mom
voted for trump
shouldn't black lives matter have to
answer when their very pictures and
quotes are shared as inspiration for a
killing yes
call me that's me mr old fashioned but
we'll lighten this up here because uh
guess what there's a here's a win we
can't get to that little one we can't
get to the opec and energy we'll have to
do it tomorrow yeah but we'll start with
it because
that's tomorrow it's a rebuttal to
trevor no because he was wrong about
that but he actually got one right
no
did he actually tell a funny joke no no
no no no he's uncapable he can't do that
baby steps okay sorry
he uh
he commented on the ceo of moderna and
vaccines and i heard it in the next room
and i actually um i mean i ran out of
the next room into this room so quickly
there was just a steven shaped cloud
where i used to be
because i thought i misheard it here it
is on the one hand
almost all the omicron cases have been
mild so far
but on the other hand
the guy who stands to gain millions of
dollars from new vaccines
says we need new vaccines
if we don't make a new vaccine this
disease could be with us ferrari i mean
forever sorry i was thinking of
something else now look i'm not saying
that the ceo of madonna is lying i'm not
saying that at all i'm just saying i
don't think he's the most objective
source on this topic well
that actually makes sense
oh sorry
[Music]
all right oh yeah joe lewis hates the
poppers
dog by poppers certainly does not that's
his through you guys i'm out of here
loving pooch who is pampered oh my gosh
uh hey you know what though look he did
get one right credit words do absolutely
um the ferrari joke we could have done
with that but yeah yes i absolutely
agree with you uh joke in the loose
sense of the word
um hey mission control uh can you change
the dartboard
[Music]
ceasefire
all right good to go
[Music]
uh well we're running out of uh running
well it's a rotation yeah it's a
rotation um
are we showing the teaser here right now
of what we're playing later or no i can
no no
what film are we doing we don't make
them like they used to it's uh the
gauntlet i don't even know what that is
um
i you know we have a whole segment here
but you know we can't go late today so
please smash if you're watching on
youtube rumble smash the like button
uh right now we're we also don't know uh
what the situation with kyle right now
let's have some pleasure we'll see
today's show will be ended a little bit
early
let me know if you want him to be here
on the show yeah maybe some people like
no when i don't think anyone's going to
respond what's wrong
people do
we want them yes we love you kyle i
really am i'm looking for i don't know
what i'm going to do i'm going to
probably hug the guy yeah this has been
an emotional year not only with that but
obviously the school shooting the suv
situation i just i don't know you know
you reach that point where you don't
know if there's any coming back from it
yeah
there is i don't know i mean i i i think
that there's a rebound effect uh but i
don't think there's any coming back from
when people say
oh americans mistrust institutions
i don't think you're ever going to have
them i don't think you're ever going to
somehow trick people into
retrusting cnn
well no i think that's that's a good
thing though yes it really is like it's
a fantastic like the hand has been laid
out very clearly it's a good thing
except for the death throes for places
like cnn like twitter when they realize
when they get caught enough times they
are going to get desperate as twitter
stock continues to take a dive you're
going to see it with all of social media
as people start unplugging you're going
to see youtube shoot themselves on the
foot and i mean this right think about
it youtube was a place for independent
content creators and now they are bowing
at the altar of really just to be clear
folks
and before i before we go this is this
is something like this is kind of one of
my litmus tests for conspiracies and
dave and i have talked about this i
don't buy into a lot of conspiracy
theories because you go all right okay
do you have any idea how many people
have to be in on that yeah i mean the
janitor that's a good ques you don't
have time to go through all conspiracy
theories because sometimes they can
convince you that when you're like wow
oh
i guess that guy was out there behind
tower seven with a plunger
um
but a good sort of test is okay how many
people have to be involved to trick the
majority society at large
in this case whether it comes to the
idea of biological sex
whether it comes to the idea of
more legal gun ownership increasing
crime
whether it comes to the idea of the
american heart association's warning
about heart complications with the mrna
vaccine being considered authoritative
when it comes to any of these
issues right and you're going well how
many people would have to be involved to
eliminate the american heart
association okay
less than 10.
think about that
less than 10 people you need one person
to make a call in the government
one person to make a call from pfizer or
moderna
you need the person who's at the head of
uh i don't know forget his name twitter
facebook
instagram it covers all those one person
at alphabet google youtube
maybe one person at amazon and one
person at uh apple
to ghost
all of it
to make sure that you don't hear the
other point of view that you don't hear
a point of view other than
one
one the american heart association is
not saying oh the vaccine is a my it's a
microchip no they're saying hey by the
way there might be an increase of of of
heart risks
what did i just rattle off seven eight
people
eight people in the world can make sure
that you never hear that information how
many of you before you started watching
this show you right now did you know
that 500 000 is the low end to 3 million
defensive uses of firearms in the united
states every year according to the fbi
fb i don't know if it's fbi crime bureau
doj it depends on the year because it's
pretty tough to get that research done
um and people will blame them on
conservatives actually no
it's because the left wanted to
selectively use these loopholes to
actually try and track americans just to
be clear i believe it's mcgrath yes
talk about eight people yeah
eight people
let's be generous 10.
that requires one conference call you
probably have had more people on a zoom
meeting than the people who can decide
that you know what
we think this uh
biden ukraine and hunter biden story
might have a negative effect on the
election one zoom call gone saw it gone
from everywhere
zoom call you know what we think that
the uh fusion gp the russia collusion i
think this is good we're going to allow
this one zoom call and we know they have
summits
i'm not talking about people dressed up
in a ram's head worshiping an owl i'm
talking about one zoom call hey hey uh
hey zuck uh sorry i won't take too much
of your time hey uh you know what let me
let me get uh let me get to mr modern on
here i don't know who's ahead of me yeah
let me get mr moderna on here and now
pfizer pick up the phone all right we
got joe hey can we just get rid of that
american heart association thing great
oh while we're at it can we label the
michigan shooter terrorist sure let's
just say waka show was a van click it
takes eight people one conference call
to make sure that you don't hear any
other points of view that has to be
destroyed
that system
not calling for violence that system
that consolidation of power
has to be
destroyed for us to rebuild if you want
a [ __ ] about division hey
amy take your ire
aim it at the 10 people right now who
are ensuring that the vision will be
sowed for the rest of your lifetime
until it gets fixed and politics start
locally all right we're going to go play
they don't make them like they used to
youtube well i think you
i believe i've made my thoughts clear
bye